o Olá a todas e todos o Marco Maciel com
quase nada que agradecer a oportunidade
de estar aqui te alugando com vocês um
pouco sobre a nossa criatividade das
ruas mas antes de chegar nossa
apresentação eu queria muito dialogar
com cada um cada um de vocês sobre o que
essa Brasília sobre o meu olhar sobre a
minha estética sobre a minha vivência né
Brasília ela foi criada na nossa
perspectiva para não ser tensão social
não é uma cidade que produziu uma lógica
desigualdade social muito tempo muito
grande sou da cidade de Ceilândia que é
uma das Primeiras Experiências no Brasil
e promoções de panela seu nome vende
centro de erradicação de invasões ou
seja os filhos daqueles que ajudaram a
construir a capital né o aquele que
ajudaram ser a capital nossos pais avó
e como chamado de é invasor de uma vez
de ser chamado trabalhadores foi
colocada muito distante do chamado
centro né ou seja se poderia estar
morando próximo do lugares nos Palácios
que a gente ajudou a construir mais bem
os colocados estrategicamente distante e
não porque a gente não cabia lá você não
quiser a gente mesmo bem É nesse cenário
que a gente presta eu sou da década de
80 cresceu na década de 90
historicamente o acompanhei a nossa
cidade que não tem conhecida como a
cidade mais violento da perigoso lugar
que querem inclusive chamado na grande
presença de caldeirão do diabo né o
barril de pólvora isso gerou um problema
na nossa adolescência e infância de
frustração né de não ter pertencimento
com território de negar as vezes no
currículo que morava aqui com tudo ali
através da cultura hip-hop reafirmando
território dando o cu para negão para
acabar Ceilândia mesmo e daí trouxe a
autoestima para gente e muito mais
começou a questionar que a gente tem
potência a gente tem
Oi gente vai se concentrar aqui a
entender essa voz felicidade é fez com
que a gente falasse Poxa bem não adianta
a gente ficar subindo não adianta a
gente ficar sendo aqui é criminalizado o
tempo todo a gente não produzir nossas
próprias ferramentas de vocalização das
nossas negativas deve ser nosso projeto
que os jovens pressão a ruas aqui no na
Ceilândia especificamente né que a
atividade das ruas fugir disso a gente
acredita fielmente da Periferia ao
centro ou seja é dela que parte a
tecnologia social a Inovação a interação
a criatividade a superação de desafios é
a periferia que faz a cidade de
funcionar todo dia e a gente costuma
dizer isso né se o café tá pronto o
ônibus para circulando é porque a
periferia chegou primeiro então a gente
já valorizar essas potências
reconhecerem como lugar de transformação
no território e mudar essa lógica de
apenas cidades-dormitório e daí essa
narrativa passar se sentavam nossa
discussão A periferia então é o centro
disso tudo
e com base nisso então a gente percebe
que não bastava só desculpa a gente vai
usar uma prática e também não bastava
apenas falar para todo mundo assim que
tem um pouco específico sobre tudo
daquela parcela da população que mais
sofre com a violência ou com a
perspectiva de desemprego que poucas
alternativas e evasão escolar e é a
parcela da Juventude Robert hoje tem 750
mil jovens aproximadamente então em 2004
realizamos uma pesquisa para todos
determinantes da violência organizado
pelo Instituto carburador e desenvolveu
a partir dali já olhar de que um jovem
negro periférica que mais morrem por
causas externas né devido às ausências
de oportunidade de outras superações E
propõe o programa Jovem de expressão e a
gente então desenvolve isso ocupam a
praça pública em Ceilândia a praça do
cidadão é uma praça que a gente tem
desenvolvido um conceito né não tem
recepção de internet sem fio a passo que
a gente tentando fazer ela gente passa
uma convivência mas também um olhar
pedagógico para além do mundo espaço
apenas um pastor referencial
a convivência Comunitária que é
primordial para o nosso desenvolvimento
e para nossa interação então a base
Central é fazer as pendências no espaço
público saudável aquele lugar que
ninguém queria ir aquele lugar que todo
mundo achava que era violenta que lugar
que ninguém reconheceu uma perspectiva
de oportunidade e passar a ser uma
referência por isso nós fizemos aqui com
a praça do cidadão e fazer um processo
de transformação social na juventude
periférica Ou seja é oportunizar eles
uma sobreposição de ações eu vou falar
mais à frente o que que essa
sobreposição de ações estrategicamente
para que ela passar da Juventude né da
Juventude são para a juventude então é o
jogo expressão tem como base isso a
gente atende jovens de 18 a 29 anos
Oi jovens hoje que é verdade diferente
da minha juventude da década de 90 né
final da década de 80 Mas como as minhas
os mesmos problemas lembra bastante
baixos tema outra perspectiva Mas com
muita vontade com muita ideia criativa e
com muito espaço para dar vazão então
aqui em média nosso passo como tava
funcionando né na academia estão uma
parada Mas quando ele funciona Ele
atende média 150 jogos e o público de 18
a 29 anos e porque de 18 a 29 anos
porque justamente essa parcela que era
dos assistindo por políticas públicas
até 2013 quando foi acionado Estatuto da
Juventude depois de tinha tu no leque
uma série de garantias mesmo deficiente
mesmo cheia de problemas Então galera
aqui né diferença adolescente a zero até
que é de 18 anos vai para a juventude
não tinha nada bem essa é um pouco do
que a gente fez a gente faz o seguinte a
revitalização da Praça do cidadão é a
repactuação no território e o direito ao
ócio criativo
é fundamental o direito ao ócio criativo
para nós porque até isso nos foi negado
historicamente Quando você vê jogos
reunidos num determinado espaço a
primeira percepção que as pessoas têm
que que ela tá fazendo nada podia tá
trabalhando porque a lógica do trabalho
serviu apenas para grande parte da
Periferia e tem que no máximo concluiu o
ensino médio e olha tem que buscar
emprego ajudar em casa urgentemente o às
vezes até abandonar a escola porque já
tinha conseguido um emprego e não tava
conseguindo conciliar então quando a
gente fala do direito ao ócio criativo
porque esse é o momento que esse jovem
ampara Aqui tem muita gente fala que ele
não estão fazendo nada a gente fala que
é bem-vindo eu não quero fazer nada que
é o número que ele vai ser ele ele vai
ter interação que vai poder outras
conversas conhecer novas pessoas tirar
uma ideia do Papel sonhar e dali criar
novas ações pode ser o topo mas para nós
tem dado muito certo e tem acontecido no
dia a dia e esse é o espaço no início à
Praça do cidadão fica na 18/20 da
Ceilândia Norte Aqui nós fizemos uma
reforma no início né temos a repactuar
ocupamos um prédio público abandonado
é configurado nesse espaço que a
realização né Eu sou mais fácil olhar
simbólico mudar o estigma né do que era
ruim porque é bom é então aqui a gente
parte para um pouco do que é o
desenvolvimento né Nós temos os
telecentros ele não acontece isso aqui
aonde está a nossa biotechtown tô
gravando agora é mas antigamente a gente
tinha os computadores liberado para
comunidade porque a gente não tem
intenção e porque a gente não tem
recepção que eu quero perguntar para os
jogos que chega aqui para onde ele vai
quando ele vem aqui porque ele teve
interesse a partir de quando ele entra
ele vai buscar acessar o serviço que a
gente está ofertando E aí a gente tem
acesso aí seu filho Barreiro sem
condicionantes para que esse jogo entre
aqui Possivelmente a gente não teria
esse fluxo ou seja uma referência para
ele porque ele já estão sobrecarregados
de pessoas dizendo prende o tempo todo
que ele tem que fazer o que fez não
podem fazer ou às vezes nem acreditando
no potencial dele então para nós é bem
vindos tente é tão junto né então aqui
um pouco da nossa biblioteca a gente tem
uma sala de formação
e o programa ele tem uma sobreposição de
ações eu falei feliz que faça
sobreposições de ações é que não dá para
apostar na juventude apenas um caminho
você acha que com o emprego emprego
vamos correr atrás de emprego mas é
outra sobreposições às vezes jovem para
aqui para um longe todo momento a
interação né É pelo momento em que a
gente pode desenvolver uma série de
ações e participações ele entra em
quando ele chega aqui ele chega com
muitas dúvidas né E essas sobreposições
de ações é o perguntar para ele vários
caminhos então a gente tem atendimento
psicológico atendimento jurídico nós
temos aqui a biblioteca acesso à
internet mas também várias oficinas de
audiovisual de propagar DJ e percussão
de teatro de produção de evento nós
temos aqui cenografia Road técnica você
não entendeu porque isso tudo e
pré-vestibular a noite que acontece com
a primeira salas ele é vários caminhos
de alternativa para esses jovens Ele vai
tentar na tentativa eu vou buscar
e aqui ocupação permanente da praça
pública né Batalha de Mc's ISO roda de
coco esperando quero que a gente
acredita pois bem muito desse jovens
chegavam aqui com a ideia e às vezes a
gente apertar vão aprender algo que eles
não tava muito afim Mas uma coisa que
nós percebemos aquele jovem também
tinham capacidade empreendedora forte a
gente tem uma ideia na cabeça para gerar
economia também seu território se
desenvolver localmente por isso que nós
temos o laboratório de empreendimentos
criativos que é justamente para
oportunizar jovens a oportunidade de
tirar uma ideia do papel e criar o seu
negócio e até você tem que ser
desenvolvimento local comunitário um
coletivo a gente não Pet empresários que
vão criar algumas ferramentas que no
final vai precarizar o trabalho na ponte
então ele quer desenvolver localmente
ele cria ele hoje né Já tem 3 anos que a
gente desenvolve ele ele ele destina a
cada ano 100 mil reais para 10
empreendimento vocês são 10 mil com a
dez Empreendimentos né Cada
empreendimento desse 10 mil e passa um
ano ali com a gente discutindo
o sucesso da rede produtiva e econômica
gestão financeira fluxo de caixa
parceria venda dependendo do formato
cooperativismo de cooperação e
cooperativismo desenvolvimento local uma
série de não temos atingir dá certo o
certo e o errado é consequência do
processo de construção sabe o que a
gente quer oportunizar esse jovem a ter
uma ideia do papel e ele sente pela
primeira vez como tirar essa ideia do
papel é ele percebeu a dificuldade e
aprimorar as suas ações né é o direito
de errar mas uns já de cara consegue
alavancar sua ideia fazer sua dessa do
portal e até melhorar com base nas
consultoria Somente o juiz que a gente
vem desenvolvendo dentro do né fia
e a gente tem também além da parte da
economia criativa da cultura O esporte
como ferramenta primordial Então já
realizamos aqui como postagem de
fidelização inclusive na praça
Campeonato de Basquete nós desenvolvemos
também campeonato de skate que é o
segundo esporte mais praticado nenhum
que hoje pode ter conhecido como atleta
mas naquela época ninguém conhecia como
atleta passatempo é este olhar de
criminalização da Periferia da juventude
que a gente fez quebrar e quer quebrar
todo dia mostrar que esses jovens são
potências em que a gente investir nele
ele pode trazer muito mais resultados
para vida dele não que ele abandonar
naquele momento tem que fazer algo que
ele não tá muito afim Acabei de chegar
às vezes até acabar com sono eu não tô
falando eu tô perguntando de realidade
né não tem que apostar para nossa
juventude a oportunidade de errar e
acertar Quem disse que quem completou 18
anos já tá formado tá pronto quem foi
que falou isso mas eu não tô talvez você
está assistindo agora também é coisa que
não está é o processo permanente para o
padrão de parte isso não é realidade e o
elemento em movimento Olha o movimento é
muito mais competiu Val do
e para vocês Azul piscina fica acontece
aqui ela ela é gessada preparado e
capacitado para realização descendente
do evento uma cidade o evento que reúne
mais de 20 mil pessoas gratuito uma
cidade Ninguém queria ver historicamente
costumo dizer que a ver o mesmo
acontecerá unilasalle imaginar pois bem
um elemento em movimento ele reúne mais
de 20 mil pessoas o mais de 300 pessoas
trabalhando diretamente a cenografia que
tava na oficina de cenografia o áudio
visual Então são de audiovisual
fotografia a fotografia EA produção de
eventos e Nossa a parte técnica do Paulo
que é Nossa Ou seja é um desenvolvimento
do nosso de preparar um laboratório para
algo real e esse esse festival deixa em
Ceilândia diretamente apenas conosco 300
mil reais fora tudo aquilo que acontece
um tempo de sinergia né então ele é
mesmo vendo esse de dupla seguinte
perspectiva não é muito mais que um
festival que vem todo o processo de isso
não é uma certa gente é um debate
político de ter centralizado
a ocupação do espaço público
empoderamento a juventude que organizam
eventos e futuro banho hip-hop tem uma
cidade que historicamente somos encarar
violento e que hoje todo mundo pede
porque nós incluímos todo toda Não mas
quase grande parte da rede produtiva de
Ceilândia dentro do festival esse que tá
gráfica daqui a camiseteria daqui as
pessoas esperam todo ano o festival tem
desenvolve localmente né E aí a gente
tem oficinas seminários Impacto social e
acesso observa já falei é que a gente
forma aqui seminário acontece três dias
do festival debatendo temas específicos
a cultura urbana da Periferia por vários
fatores sociais e políticos do país
inteiro e pacto social a gente tem
carbono fino nesse evento a gente faz um
processo de reflorestamento né auxilia
vou passar reflorestamento de Mata
Atlântica compensando o carbono que a
gente gera pelo cálculo que a gente faz
e também todo processo de lixo né a
coleta orgânica vai para o processo de
adubo de processo
é a parte também do reciclado a gente
distribuir para cooperativas conveniadas
Formoso e o acesso o que a gente faz de
tudo para aquela pessoa chega e volte
para casa o quanto antes pois tem
parceria começou a distribuir algumas
pulseiras e parte vai no festival entra
gratuito que aquele 10 Hyster economizou
um transporte ele gasta nesse nosso
evento Então é isso não é uma expressão
da Juventude uma expressão do território
eu queria agradecer você que o tempo
percurso passa tanta coisa sinergia que
a gente faz vai dizer que é possível e
que no nosso site jovens e pressão
1.com.br em toda a nossa tecnologia
social em nossas pesquisas nosso
monitoramento a nossa avaliação objetivo
central e dizer que nós lá atrás
poderíamos talvez ser nenhum problema
nenhum problema Apenas mais um nesse
cenário e tantos eles desenharam o
caminho da Juventude foi traçado por
pessoas que não incluíram a juventude
nesse processo o que nós fizemos agora
foi mudar a rota e dizer que em frente o
processo de linha de vida
e tem que ficar discutindo sem com ele e
que nós podemos essa sobreposição de
ações que eu falei da oportunidade é
isso que transforma E é isso que a gente
acredita muito obrigado tá que o povo
das nossas redes sociais aí e todas as
plataformas e Acerola e
E aí
[Música]